well we're just days away from triple
digit heats and envy energy is getting
ready for summer jeremy j ford was out
at a generating station in the north
part of the valley with the behind the
scenes tour as crews prepared to battle
the heat
[Music]
this is the envy energy silver hawk
power plant which is currently closed
for scheduled maintenance the purpose is
to upgrade machinery and equipment to
make sure that they can be back and
ready to serve the community throughout
the summer months we happen every four
to five years depending upon run time of
our turbines senior director of
generation jason hemmons tells me
everything from rotors and pumps to
valves and motors will be serviced the
scope of this outage we're removing the
rotor we've actually got
a new one that will be
prepping for installation in the units
hammond says some of the equipment
components take time to service and
install therefore the outage allows
workers to make necessary fixes we're
focused on maintenance
we're also doing some combustion turbine
upgrades that will allow us to have some
additional capacity for the summer
months an effort to make sure there's
backup power storage for users if they
happen to lose power we want to have our
plants reliable and there when customers
need it all year round
but for us during the summer those are
the critical months of the year
jeremy j ford live
local now
by the way the silverhawk station
provides more than 130 customers with
power the maintenance will be complete
by the end of the month